more than a dozen Democratic Democratic
presidential candidates have called for
the Attorney General to release the
Muller report one of those candidates
asking to see the entire report is
Senator Kamala Harris from the
California Democrat made that demand at
a campaign stop in Atlanta where she
also unveiled a new plan to increase pay
for public school teachers nationwide
now it's part of our road to 2020 she is
discussing the details only on CBS this
morning senator Harris joins us from
Washington senator good morning great to
have you on I want to get to your
education plan in just a moment but I do
want to begin with the news of day and
that is the Justice Department is
reversing its course now saying that the
entire Affordable Care Act should be
invalidated
what toll are all these legal battles on
the Affordable Care Act having on the
program itself and how will it sit with
voters so bianna when I was Attorney
General of California we defended the
Affordable Care Act and the need for its
existence listen I'm traveling around
the country these days as you know and
one of the the main things that keeps
people up at night that they worry about
is whether they're going to have access
to affordable health care and the
Affordable Care Act brought health care
to millions tens of millions and people
that otherwise didn't have it I feel
very strongly that supposedly ders
should stop playing politics with
people's public health people want to
know that pre-existing conditions will
not be a barrier to them receiving
mehelphelp care was a huge issue during
the midterms expecting the same in 2023
sure yes
you're right it's still an issue it is
what keeps people up at night and what
also keeps people up at night our wages
specifically for teachers and that's
something that you're talking about
today you are announcing that you have a
plan that will invest in American
teachers and give them a $13,500 raise
to close the teacher pay gap as you call
it that is a very lofty ambition and you
should be commended for it but the big
question is how are you gonna pay for it
sure well first of all you know I look
at my friends are successful in the
private sector and
I admire that they understand that we
really should look at these things
through the lens of whether it is a
we're going to get the return on the
investment so let's look at it as an
investment we can judge a society I
think always by the way it treats its
children and one of the greatest
expressions of love of our children is
that we invest in their education the
people who are going to educate our
children are our teachers and for too
long they have been paid substandard
wages and certainly not being paid their
value to us as a society and to our
children so I am proud of our initiative
that has been described as the largest
federal investment in closing the
teacher pay gap in history I think that
there is no question that we all know
there are two groups of people who are
raising our children it's our parents
which could be grandparents aunties and
uncles and it's our teachers so let's
play it pay them their value so how did
you come up with the figure of 13,500
and I'm still not sure how you're gonna
pay for it sure so we're gonna pay for
it by adjusting the the estate tax right
now it's only eleven million dollars and
up and we need to lower that so that we
can actually pay what we want in terms
of knowing that we want to invest in our
teachers and and the future of our
country in terms of how we came about
this legislation it's simple I've been
traveling the country meeting teachers
were working two jobs sometimes three
over ninety percent of our teachers are
coming out of their own pocket to pay
for school supplies no I'm talking about
a figure senator yep that's a terrific
figure
sure count so the data is very clear
that teachers are as compared to other
college graduates receiving 11% less and
pay across the country so we have data
that supports this point and that is the
equivalent of about thirteen thousand
five hundred dollars a year and thirteen
thousand five hundred dollars a year is
the equivalent of a year's worth of
mortgage payments the equivalent of a
year's worth of grocery bills the
equivalent of paying down student loans
for a year so it's a very significant
amount of money so senator what we
should remind bill that 50 million kids
are in public schools so this would
affect a huge group of families a couple
of criticism
you're likely to get first is the sort
of federalism argument that this is a
education should be a state issue yes
there's federal funds but it's better
when it's closer to the local level how
does that affect or what's your response
to that with respect to the pay raise I
think we can look at history to give us
a guide on this LBJ was probably the
last president who really put a
substantial investment in the public
education system of our country and we
reaped huge rewards for that and that's
how I think of this where the states
cannot act we should actually support
them and so specifically what we are
proposing is that there would be a
federal match three to one in terms of
what the states can give and then what
the federal government will give to
match state funding and I'll tell you
John it's important to understand this
is not a partisan issue you could look
at the teachers in Oklahoma and Arizona
so-called red states which have who have
demanded better equity around salaries
and we know it's because we have to
understand that the education of the
children of America is not a partisan
issue and it should be a nonpartisan
issue so there's obviously the equity
question on what people are getting paid
just for doing an honest day's work
going back to your original point though
in terms of improving the outcomes for
kids are you do you expect some kind of
benefit here in terms of recruiting new
people to come into the teaching
profession lutely and also and what
about outcomes that in terms of what the
studies have shown that might improve
from this bump up and pay you're
absolutely right it's going to be about
recruitment and retention we want that
that student who is excelling in
chemistry and biology that they will
pursue their passion of teaching
children instead of worrying about how
they're going to pay off their student
loans and going to some pharmaceutical
company we want that that that
mathematician who wants to teach our
children math we'll do that instead of
going to Wall Street because they got to
pay off their bills so there is gonna
humor tension piece of it and there's
another factor also which we have built
into this which is for the those school
districts that have the highest needs so
for example rural school districts where
there is a difficult it is difficult to
recruit people that we're actually going
to bump up the federal match to those
areas so we can create incentives
for these smart people these teachers to
go to areas where otherwise there are
not enough teachers to teach the
children of those communities all right
senator Harris that's all the time we
have thanks very much for being with us
I appreciate you thank you again soon
thank you thank you